hosanna padang de brito est en deuil
avec plus de 400 mille morts de la coved
beaucoup de familles brésiliennes sont
touchés en octobre dernier elle a perdu
son père un colonel de l'armée
brésilienne de soixante dix huit ans en
pleine forme physique
les classes privilégiées la société ne
sont pas mieux protégés que les autres
ce fumeur de pipe ne supportait pas le
masque il tombe malade dix mois après la
mort de sa femme victime d'un cancer
si l'hôpital militaire l'avait acceptée
la première fois il ne serait pas mort
dit rosanna quand il l'a fait c'était
trop tard il est entré à l'hôpital lundi
sept jours plus tard il était mort la
semaine suivante son ongle officier de
marine qui avait dix ans de moins que
son père réfractaire aux masques
également entre au prestigieux hôpital
de la marine brésilienne
il est un tube il deuxième jour et le
troisième il meurt à perdre à il doit
axer paulo qui n'a pas les serbes ashton
efficace on leur a offert de la
chloroquine qu'ils ont refusé
contrairement à leurs cousins qui en ont
pris en prévention il était partisan du
président jacques bolson à eau ils ont
suivi ces conseils et bien ils ont tous
attrapé l'aco vide ce sont tous des
victimes de la seconde vague de l'aco
vide plus mortel que la première
six membres de la famille de sébastien
ans aux arrêts sont attrapés l'aco vide
en avril 2001 plusieurs ont failli
passer mais ils ont survécu à gaza city
wendel sébastian l'attraper d'un jeune
collègue sur un chantier de construction
mais lui il a vraiment souffert et
kostas et il vaut le 6 mai un an plus
tard il ressent encore plusieurs des
symptômes inapte à récupérer sa femme
toni n'y a moins affecté à pul soigner
mais ils ont contaminé le fils ottavio
qui lui aussi souffre encore de
séquelles de son tour à tour soit en
ligne ou la première vague était
peut-être moins mortel métaux niña est
catégorique s'il était allé à l'hôpital
il serait mort ok au risque du prd duvet
de la bei maejor ils ont perdu ainsi une
voisine et dans le quartier il ya
beaucoup d'orphelins le quartier c'est
la rocinha la plus grande favela de rio
le port du masque le respect des
distances dans ce dédale d'habitation ou
si compact et surpeuplé sont des
consignes difficile à suivre et tout le
monde ne croit pas encore assez à la
gravité de la pandémie le variant p1 qui
a frappé l amazonie en janvier compte
maintenant pour plus de 90% des cas et
il est beaucoup plus virulent
heureusement les deux vaccins sont
efficaces mais seulement 15% de la
population brésilienne jusqu'ici a reçu
une première dose
jean michel leprince radio canada rio de
janeiro